bonjour nous sommes en direct ce
mercredi soir pour votre rendez-vous
habituel c'est suite de la question du
jour vous le connaissez tous les jours
Le Figaro vous pose une question sur son
site internet et vous demande d'y
répondre et aujourd'hui on vous demande
si la France doit livrer ou non aussi
des chars lourds à l'Ukraine et pour en
parler je suis avec Nicolas Barotte au
service du Figaro bonjour Nicolas
bonjour
c'est un sujet qu'on voit venir souvent
dans l'actualité depuis quelques
semaines alors est-ce que vous pouvez
déjà nous raconter rapidement un peu ce
qui se passe en ce moment autour des
Charlots on parie de charléger il y a
encore deux semaines et là maintenant
c'est des Charlots oui il y a quelques
semaines la France à un ancienne envoi
de Charles léger des amx-10rc alors
c'est quoi la différence entre un char
léger et un charlot c'est un débat
d'expert de spécialistes Grosso ça tient
au blindage au poids du véhicule le char
lourd par définition il est davantage
plus protégée que le char à mx-10 qui
est plus rapide mais plus vulnérable au
tir adverse donc pourquoi est-ce qu'on
en parle beaucoup mais parce que les
Ukrainiens ont réclament en demande pour
pouvoir tenir tête à la Russie et
éventuellement mener une offensive sur
le terrain il leur faut un avantage
technologique et c'est pas qu'il le
demande des chats aux Occidentaux et
donc on a beaucoup tergiverser et au
bout du compte les Allemands ont décidé
de livrer des chats léopard 2 alors
pourquoi c'est important parce que en
Europe c'est le plus gros stock en fait
c'est le chat le plus répandu pour être
un peu rapide qui conçu par les
Allemands et qui les a vendus je n'en
beaucoup de pays européens et donc il y
a beaucoup de lots par deux qui sont
disponibles et donc c'est pour ça c'est
important que les Allemands donnent leur
aval parce qu'une fois qu'ils ont donné
la ravale d'autres pays ont le droit eux
aussi ont les Polonais par exemple dans
dans livrer aux Ukrainiens c'est un peu
une clause dans les contrastes c'est à
dire en gros
l'Allemagne va vendre des chars à
d'autres pays en leur disant on vous
donne des chars vous en faites ce que
vous voulez mais par contre si les
donner à d'autres pays il va falloir
nous prévenir il va falloir qu'on soit
d'accord ça qui se passe c'est ça c'est
c'est des règles d'exportation qui sont
en plus importantes qu'en Allemagne donc
c'est très sensible comme sujet et donc
le gouvernement allemand était très
sourcil très vigilant à ne pas fournir
des armes à des pays qui pourraient
ensuite les livrer à d'autres pays tiède
pour des guerres des fins qui seraient
jugés non conforme ou non voulu parler
d'argent donc ils ont mis cette clause
de de non-exportation sauf à corps donc
ce qui pose souvent des grosses
difficultés on a vu au début de la
guerre il y a des armements qui étaient
qui étaient bloqués parce que justement
il fallait l'autorisation du Bundestag
en Allemagne et là pour les chats
c'était critique avec une dimension très
symbolique parce qu'effectivement est-ce
que c'est pas franchir un échelon un pas
supplémentaire dans dans la guerre nous
allons sont très réticents et il ne
voulait pas
que des Russes puissent les accuser
d'avoir eux-mêmes est-ce qu'elle a dit
comme on dit le conflit en livrant des
chars allemands donc il y a eu un long
processus politique à Berlin comme
souvent pour aboutir à une décision
favorable de livraison de charges oui
parce que c'est c'est toujours la
question dans ce cas là c'est que on
livre déjà mais il ne faut pas faire
partie des belligérants de ce conflit
pour pas que les Russes attaquent
des pays il y a toujours une marge très
fine sur laquelle il faut évoluer oui en
fait c'est en fait c'est un débats un
peu qui est un peu abscon en réalité
parce que on va bien depuis le début du
conflit on a livré beaucoup de beaucoup
d'armements de l'artillerie des
munitions des des systèmes radars etc
etc donc fournir des chars ça va
vraiment en soi une escalade de
cobelligence ça n'existe pas trop c'est
soit on a des soldats sur le terrain qui
se battent avec les Ukrainiens dans ce
cas effectivement on est cobelligérant
soit on leur fournit et du matériel mais
on n'est pas vraiment un impliqué dans
le sens on n'est pas dans le conflit
c'est donc il y a une rhétorique russe
pour faire peur aux occidentaux pour
leur dire attention si vous avez trop
loin on va réagir ils sont pas réagir
pour l'instant et donc livrer des chats
sinon ça n'a pas entraîné une attaque
des Russes contre les positions des
Occidentaux de l'OTAN donc ce débat là
il faut pas non plus
l'exagérer même si en Allemagne il y a
une sensibilité à la guerre qui est un
peu particulière et donc une réticence
de l'opinion une difficulté à se dire
qu'ils vont quand même soutenir un pays
en guerre avec leur propre matériel là
on leur demande un peu un saut
psychologique qui n'était pas simple
d'autant plus que Scholtz je choisis à
une coalition avec le SPD les Verts et
les libéraux qui est un peu compliqué à
gérer qui demande du temps justement
pour pour surmonter ces difficultés
alors je salue Joe cost Christelle qui
nous a rejoint dans le chat VLF qui nous
dit Poutine ne s'arrêtera seulement que
quand tu auras perdu sur le terrain
militaire donc il faut livrer des chats
évidemment même des avions de chasse
selon lui alors pour revenir un peu sur
ces chars léopards les chars léopard
donc il y en a beaucoup en Europe
comment ça se fait qu'il y en ait
finalement autant c'est l'Allemagne en
fait qui a réussi qui a réussi à avoir
le marché entre guillemets oui c'est ça
c'est il y a c'est un succès
d'exportation euh c'est un char qui a
une très bonne réputation qui est très
performant et donc qui a été acheté par
par la Pologne par la publique tchèque
par la Pays-Bas la Suisse il y a eu
beaucoup c'était comparé au Leclerc qui
est plutôt un échec pour le coup qui est
un échec à l'exportation les Léopards
qui est un choc en fait dans à la fin
des 70 donc c'est c'est assez vieux il y
a eu plusieurs versions successives
entre le 2 le 2A etc de S6 de à 7 pour
la dernière on va pas ouvrir toute
l'histoire mais voilà ça a été un chat
qui a été joué performant et qui a pu
être vendu par les allemands dont les
chiffres c'est gros 2000 2000
exemplaires en Europe ce qu'il y a un
avantage chez comptable de pièces
détachées ce qui est très important pour
le conflit on pourra aller puiser
facilement des pièces de rechange pour
aller réparer sur le terrain des des
chars qui seraient endommagés alors que
à l'inverse une collection des c'était
Leclerc souvent il y a peu de Leclerc
donc même si on en fourni après pour
donner des éléments de petite détachés
ce serait très compliqué et assez vite
on arriverait à la limite avec les
Léopards là pour le coup il y a cette
profondeur cette capacité à soutenir sur
du long terme et des chats je vais vous
montrer juste cette infographie qui est
paru dans le Figaro justement les
Léopards il y en aura environ 2000 les
challenger
du Royaume-Uni il y en aurait un peu
plus de 200 les chars américains des
Abrahams 2600 mais bon c'est des
États-Unis moins facile elle va venir et
les chars Leclerc dont on va parler
c'est 220 chats voilà les chats Leclerc
c'est ils sont beaucoup moins nombreux
alors on va faire direct vendredi
dernier je me rappelle pour en parler et
vous me disiez bah la question est posée
pas forcément de livrer des chars
Leclerc parce que c'est pas facile c'est
pas le plus intelligent à faire
finalement non non parce que
il faut dans la guerre avoir une forme
de simplicité qui est c'est que si on
multiplie si les Ukrainiens multiplie le
type de charme du dispose à gérer c'est
très compliqué pour les équipages pour
la logistique parce qu'il va pouvoir pas
forcément les mêmes pièces détachées
formation c'est des choses toutes bêtes
et quand on va former des temps kystes
Ukrainiens on va leur expliquer où se
situe les différentes manettes si il va
prendre 4 types de chars parce qu'ils
changent c'est impossible donc on voit
bien la dimension politique et ce qui a
motivé les Britanniques comme les
américains a décidé de livrer aussi des
challengers et des Abrahams parce qu'il
fallait donner un signal de soutien à
l'Ukraine et aussi un signal à
l'Allemagne pour lui dire tu n'es pas la
seule à fournir des chars pour les pour
les Français le gouvernement reste cette
position dire c'est trop compliqué
logistiquement ce qui est vrai par
ailleurs c'est que pour déployer un
escadron de Charles Leclerc sur le
terrain il faudrait mettre en place une
chaîne logistique énorme et donc ce
serait compliqué coûteux peu efficace et
comme vous l'avez montré on a peu de
char en stock et donc de l'armée de
terre ça va très envie de se
déposséder peu de chat pour un effet sur
latéral qui sera limité de 220 chars que
possèdent la France et là par exemple
l'Ukraine
des articles ils en demandent 300
finalement en fait finalement il y a que
les Léopards qui peuvent les aider enfin
qui peut les qui peuvent avoir un vrai
impact et ce que vous pouvez faire les
Abrahams et les challengers anglais ils
vont leur en donner deux trois pour dire
regarder nous aussi on vous les donne
c'est ça alors qu'on a sur un escadron
donc une quinzaine sur les Abrahams on
va attendre des déclarations de jobidan
qui vont pas tarder enfin aujourd'hui et
précisera le chiffre on parle d'une
trentaine donc effectivement c'est c'est
pas négligeable c'est important mais
pour avoir la masse effectivement
pouvoir les renouveler les remplacer sur
le terrain il faut puiser dans les
Léopards on va pas arriver à 300 parce
que là les annonces qui ont été faites
par les Allemands c'est de doter deux
bataillons de chats donc grosso c'est
une centaine de chars 80 et 100 tout
dépend comment on est-ce que les
Allemands veulent dire précisément mais
on est sur ce volume là une centaine
alors c'est pas les seuls chars dont
dispose les Ukrainiens sous le terrain
parce qu'ils ont aussi leur propre
charités de l’air soviétique 72 plus
qu'ils ont récupéré de l'armée russe qui
dans ces différentes retraites depuis
depuis 11 mois à abandonner aussi des
équipements que les Ukrainiens récupérés
et qui ont permis de recompléter de
renforcer leur propre capacité mais qui
sont moins performants que des gens
occidentaux qui sont plus modernes oui
c'est ça parce que jusque là et
l'éruptions non aussi ils ont déjà on va
dire traditionnels enfin plus ancien
plus anciens qui qui date des années
60-70 ils en avaient 850 au début du
conflit et même ils ont presque enfin
ils ont plus de charpe au début parce
qu'ils ont capturé plus que ce qu'ils en
ont perdu le premier le premier
fournisseur en charge de l'armée
ukrainienne c'est l'armée russe en
réalité donc faut pas non plus l'oublier
donc tout ne repose pas que sur les
Occidentaux mais c'est vrai que cette
avantage technologique est très
important parce que on voit bien que
face à la masse de l'armée russe avoir
une super technologique fournie par
l'Occident c'est important même chose
c'est quelque chose très très concrètes
c'est que la portée de tir d'un achat à
léopard sera plus longues que celle d'un
chat russe et 72 par exemple donc ça
permet de frapper l'ennemi sans que
l'autre ne puisse riposter et donc de
fait ça donne un avantage réel de même
ce sont des charmes modernes qui peuvent
tirer en roulant c'est à dire qu'on peut
mener une offensive tirer alors que des
charpes anciens peuvent avancer
s'arrêter tirer donc ils sont
vulnérables donc c'est plein de petites
choses qui est pas Macron aux ukraines
de compenser la moindre masse anti
dispose sur le terrain très bien
effectivement
donc il y a aussi une question
logistique avant de répondre à la
question du jour rapidement je voulais
savoir une question logistique comment
on amène des chars jusqu'en Ukraine
après ça c'est tout dépend de où il part
déjà et ensuite ils peuvent être
transportés par train ou par
camion tout dépend on avait bien vu un
peu ce drôle de sketch pour acheminer
des chars de claires en Roumanie pour la
France parce que il n'avait pas eu le
droit des Allemands des transporter sur
des camions donc c'est chargé sur des
trains parce que la législation dans les
différentes pays européens peuvent
varier sur la charge qu'on a le droit
d'emporter donc c'est aussi pour ça que
ça va prendre du temps à arriver en
Ukraine c'est quoi là on décide
aujourd'hui nous allons céder
aujourd'hui de livrer ses chars mais ils
ne seront pas en Ukraine avant plusieurs
semaines ça se trouve au mois de mars
plus la formation il y a la formation
des pilotes et des et des tireurs et
ensuite il y a acheminer recensé quel
chat précisément seront envoyés les
acheminées ça prend un peu de temps
parce que il faut effectivement les
mettre sur camion sur train on s'est
arrivé de transporter jusqu'au front
c'est c'est compliqué à organiser alors
je salue Christian et en tout ça et
valpazu qui nous rejoignent pour la fin
de ce direct on va que je vais quand
même vous poser la question selon vous
Nicolas est-ce que la France doit ou pas
livrer des chars lourds en Ukraine
malgré tout ce qu'on a dit je pense que
oui parce que politiquement ça a du sens
sur le terrain on voit bien que c'est
pas forcément très efficace mais en même
temps livré un escadron de de Leclerc
c'est pas ça qui va rendre la France
vulnérable à quoi que ce soit
politiquement c'est un signal très fort
et ça a renforcera même si c'est un
faible niveau aussi les capacités
ukrainiennes donc je pense que les
réticences françaises à ne pas vouloir
livrer des deux claires même si on les
comprend enfin du rationnel elle ne
franchise pas le le pas politiquement
symboliquement fourni des deux claires
sera du sang assez bizarre que les
Britanniques le fassent les Abrahams les
Américains ne fassent aussi les
Allemands et que nous on a duré des
AMX-10 donc c'est un geste qui est
destiné en plus c'est les premiers mais
on va bien
du Leclerc effectivement alors on va
cliquer sur Oui pour voir ce qu'on
répondu nos internautes au Figaro oh là
là c'est plus c'est plus la bonne page
attendez je viens de me perdre dans mes
onglets mais je vous voilà hop
excusez-moi hop pour voir donc croiser
sur Oui et les interdits du client alors
c'est très partagé très partagé mais
c'est un peu à l'image des des des des
commentaires qu'on a juste là parce que
on a à la fois des commentaires qui
disent oui bien sûr j'avais value pas du
tout à l'heure qui me disait oui on
aurait déjà dû le faire et d'autres qui
me disent attention à ne pas aller trop
loin dans la guerre finalement c'est
c'est aussi de prendre de conception qui
qui comment dire qui s'exprime depuis le
début de cette guerre absolument c'est
il y a la volonté de pas être dans
l'engrenage il y a une approche très
rationnelle de quoi est-ce que les
Ukrainiens ont vraiment besoin et mais
l'action des deux Leclerc n'écoute pas
les autres et qu'il faut leur fournir
des munitions du carburant de
l'artillerie des défenses solaires mais
symboliquement des chars lourds ça aussi
du sens même si c'est pas ça qui fera
c'est pas les Leclerc qui fera la
différence contrairement à au César qui
sont beaucoup plus simple à maintenir
sur le terrain si on en voit que 18
Césars c'est très efficace du Leclerc
c'est compliqué mais symboliquement
c'est quand même important c'est pour ça
que le gouvernement ne l'exclut pas
c'est que quand on en pose la question
au président ou ministre il ne répondent
toujours en exclue pas en étudie la
livraison pour voir ce qui est possible
parce que assumer un nom ce serait trop
compliqué politiquement très bien merci
beaucoup Nicolas d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous les Antoine du Figaro
également de nous avoir suivis d'avoir
posé de nombreuses questions la suite du
programme pour vous ce sera à 18h avec
point de vue donc on vous donne
rendez-vous restez sur le site du Figaro
et on vous dit à bientôt pour de
nouveaux live sur fear live